[موسيقى]
م
الخير الايجابيه كلمه كلنا بنسمع عنها
كتير كتير جدا في كتير منا هتلاقيهم قروا
كتب عن الايجابيه الطاقه الايجابيه قروا
مقولات كتيره عن الطاقه الايجابيه
وتاثيرها على عقليتنا تاثيرها على طريقه
تفكيرنا تاثيرها على قراراتنا سواء في
المستوى الشخصي او في المستوى
العملي احنا هنتكلم النهارده جاي اتكلم
معاكم على الموضوع بطريقه مختلفه شويه هو
ازاي ان احنا نتج نتجنب السلبيه الناتجه
من كلمه لا من كلمه
بس الاول عايز اسالكم سؤال واللي موافق لو
سمحتوا يرفع ايده مين فينا تقال له لا وهو
صغير على حاجه كان نفسه يشتريها او كان
سفريه كان نفسه يسافرها او هوايه نفسه
يمارسها او رياضه نفسه يحترف فيها او
مدرسه يدخلها او كليه يدخلها او
شغل طيب واضح ان انا مش انا لوحدي كلنا
اقال لنا لا في كل مستو في كل راحت حياتنا
اتقال لنا لا واحنا في البيت اتقال لنا لا
واحنا في المدرسه اتقال لنا لا واحنا في
الشغل بس ممكن واحد يجي يقول لي الطبيعي
ان احنا نسمع كلمه لا احنا مش عايشين في
المدينه الفاضله علشان كل حاجه تطلبها
تتحقق لك احنا مش عايشين في فيلم كرتون
علشان كل الاحلام بتاعتك وكل الخيالات
بتاعتك تبقى حقيقه ده حتى في فيلم الكرتون
بتاع علاء الدين لما لقى المصباح لما عمل
المصباح طلق له منه الجني قاله قال له
شبيك لبيك نفسك في ايه قال له انا نفسي في
حاجات كتيره قوي قال له ليك سبع سبع
امنيات بس قول له قال له اوكي انا عايز
امنيه واحده بس هي ان ياسمين تحبني
وتتجوزني قال له ها لا
برض كلنا بنسمع
لا
المشكله ان لا دي مش موجوده عندنا بس في
ناس ممكن تفتكر ان هي موجوده في بلدنا وفي
ثقافتنا بس انما هنلاقي ان في كل ثقافات
العالم وفي كل بلدان العالم
كلهم بيقولوا لا وكلهم بيرفضوا الطبيعي
انك ترفض المشكله مش في الرفض المشكله في
طريقه الرفض لو جينا بصينا على اللغه
العربيه عندنا لو ابتدينا باللغه العربيه
الفصحى هنلاقي ان طرق النفي كتيره جدا
هنلاقي لا ولم وليس وكل ولات
ولم كتير ولو جينا بصينا للغه العاميه
هنلاقي فكك كبر دماغك ايهي كلام اللي انت
بتقوله ده سيبك ممكن نقعد فيهم ا لغايه
بكره الصبح على الطريقه اللي احنا بنن في
بيها الطريقه اللي احنا بنرفض بيها فكره
طبيعي ان انت تترفض طبيعي ان انت مش كل
الافكار اللي اللي بتجي لك تتحقق او الناس
توافقك عليها الرفض طبيعي المشكله في
طريقه الرفض في ناس ممكن يرفضوا فكره
بطريقه متحضره جدا ويديلك بدالها حلول وفي
ناس ممكن يرفضوا الفكره بتاعتك بطريقه في
غايه السلبيه لدرجه ان هم يقتلوا حلمك
ويقتلوا الابداع اللي عندك وده اللي في
الاخر بيخلي ان في دول اسمها الدول
المتقدمه ودول اسمها الدول الناميه طريقه
الرفض طريقه السلبيه طريقه قتل
الحلم وانا في المدرسه ا في ثانويه عامه
طبعا اللي منكم داخل ثانويه عامه يعرف ان
بيتقاله ان دي السنه اللي بتحدد فيها
مصيره وحياته الجايه كلها بتتحدد على
اداؤه في الثانويه
العامه حصلت مشكله عندنا في في المدرسه
ونزلت لصاحب المدرسه او مدير المدرسه ا
راجل بقى فاهم في التعليم اكبر مني خبرته
كبيره جدا الراجل ده قال لي كلمتين قال لي
رامي انت هتسقط في الثانويه العامه وانت
ما فيش منك امل اوكي شاب او طفل في
الثانويه العامه الموضوع مش مستاهل ضغط مش
مستاهل اي توتر وصاحب المدرسه بيقول له
انت هتسق بس كان ساعتها قدامي حل من اثنين
يا اما اسمع له علشان هو هو اكبر مني
وبيفهم احسن مني وخبرته اكبر مني وده راجل
يعني المفروض ان هو في مجال التعليم قوي
جدا واستسلم للامر الواقع وابتدي ادور على
سواء بقى مدرسه تانيه ادخلها او اشوف
الجامعه او المعهد اللي هدخله او ان انا
اخد قرار وما اسمعش الكلام ده ماسمعش كلمه
لا بتاعته ماسمعش كلمه انت مش هتعرف
ماسمعش السلبيه اللي جايه منه الموضوع مش
سهل الموضوع محتاج تدريب الموضوع محبط
للغايه
الحل ليه ان انت يبقى عندك هدف الهدف ده
ممكن يبقى بعيد قوي ومش واضح وده الطبيعي
في سننا او في السن اللي انا بتكلم عليه
ان انت يبقى انت عايز تعمل حاجه بس هي مش
باينه مافيش اي مشاكل ان الحلم بتاعك
ملامحه ما تبقاش باينه الحلم انت عارف هو
فين وبتحاول تتجه ناحيته لما بتركز عليه
مش هتسمع السلبيه دي او هتحاول ما تسمعها
او على الاقل هتحاول تخليها ما تثر عليك
ليه عشان انت عندك حاجه عايز توصل لها
الهدف بتاعي في الموضوع ده ان انا كنت
عايز ابقى انسان كويس بشتغل شغل كويس عايش
حاجه كويسه وكان وجهه نظري ان انا هوصل
لده عن طريق كليه
الصيدله المهم ركزت في المذاكره بتاعتي
تعبت عملت اللي انا اقدر اعمله مافيش حاجه
تانيه اقدر اعملها وطلعت النتيجه لما طلعت
النتيجه انا انا شخصيا اتفاجئ انا الموضوع
ده طلعت اول المدرسه واول المنطقه
التعليميه
اول بالرغم من ان انا كنت طالب متوسط طول
حياتي في المدرسه وبعد كده في الكليه برض
بس يعني خلينا في المدرسه دلوقتي
ا اول حاجه عملتها كنت كنت رايح التمرين
بتاعي كنت بلعب تنس ساعتها اخدت الشنطه
بتاعتي ونزلت رحت المدرسه اول حاجه دخلت
لصاحب المدرسه قلت له صباح الخير انا رامي
بشرى انت قلت لي انا هسقط وانا طلعت اول
المدرسه
بتاعتك
اوكي وهنا كانت المفاجاه الاكبر المفاجاه
التانيه الراجل فاجئي يعني هو مازال
بيفاجئ لغايه دلوقتي قال لي يا حبيبي انا
كنت بشجعك انا كنت بزق ك لقدام بتشجع مين
ازاي ازاي بتشجعني ودي ودي نقطه مهمه جدا
دي طريقه التشجيع دي طريقه
التشجيع اللي طالعه من السلبيه اللي نتيجه
السلبيه كميه السلبيه الشديده اللي احنا
محاطين بيه لدرجه ان هو فاكر ان هو بيشجعك
لما يقوللك مش تعرف لما يقول لك ان انت
هتسقط لما يقول لك ان انت ما فيش منك امل
ده التشجيع ارفض الكلام ده ما توافقش عليه
وما
تسمعوش
احنا كنا بنتكلم على الهدف ان هو بعيد ومش
واضح و كل ما بتحقق حاجه صغيره الهدف
بتاعك بيوضح اكتر انا الحمد لله دخلت كليه
الصيدله وعدت سنه اولى وسنه تانيه واكتشفت
اكتشاف مهم جدا ده اللي غير حياتي كلها
وغير مجال شغلي كله وغير
انا شفت ان انا بقيت انسان احسن بعد بعد
القرار ده او الاكتشاف اللي انا اكتشفته
اكتشفت حاجه ان انا مش هشتغل في كليه
الصيدله ان انا الدراسه دي مش عجباني مع
الاحترام لكل الصيادله اللي هنا وان انا
دي مش هتبقى حياتي وخدت القرار
ده وما كنتش عارف انا عايز ايه طب هل انا
هحول طب بشري هل هحول طب اسنان هل هرجع
ثانويه عامه تاني وادخل كليه الهندسه اللي
انا كنت عايز ادخلها انا مش عارف انا مش
عارف انا عايز ايه ليه الحلم بتاعي بعيد
ومش واضح الملامح بتاعته لكن في حاجه
واحده بس اللي انا عارفها الحاجه الواحده
اللي انا عارفها ومتاكد منها ان انا مش
عايز كليه
الصيدله ودي كفيه جدا في المرحله اللي زي
دي لو انت الحلم بتاعك بعيد ومش واضح ولسه
الملامح بتاعته مش باينه بس انت عارف انت
مش عايز ايه ده رائع خليك على كده اكتفي
باللي موجود ده ده اللي خليك
تكمل ده الجزء الاولاني اللي انا كنت عايز
اتكلم عليه ان احنا ازاي نتجنب السلبيه
الشديده الناتجه من كلمه
لا الجزء التاني هو مختلف
شويه ان انت لازم يبقى عندك القوه والقدره
انك تقف وتقول
لا ستيف جوبز في مره قال الابدا
هو ان انت تقول لا لف فكره الابداع هو انت
تقول لا لف حاجه كلنا ممكن نستغرب لما
نسمع الكلام ده ازاي ببساطه هو عنده هدف
حاجه عايز يوصلها لو كان وافق على كل فكره
بتتقدم لله وعلى كل راي بيتقاله وقعد يقول
اه ما قالش لا عمر ما هو كان هيبقى ستيف
جوبز ولا عمر شركته
كانتل مؤسس الانستجرام
وهو في الدراسه بتاعته جالله اوفر او
جالله عرض من فيسبوك علشان يشتغل عندهم
تخيلوا فيسبوك اكبر شركه في السوشيال
ميديا بتطلب من طالب ان هو يجي يشتغل
عندها الولد ده كان عنده حلم هو كان عايز
يخلص الدراسه بتاعته عشان في حاجه كان
عايز يعملها ووقف وقال لفيسبوك لا وبعد ما
عمل انستجرام باع انستجرام لفيسبوك
بملايين اكبر بكتير من اللي كان هيعملها
في حياته كلها في الشغل في الفيسبوك
لازم تعرف تقف وتقول
لا لما خلصت
الجامعه قعدت شويه من غير شغل وجالي عرضين
من شركتين ادويه يعتبروا اكبر شركتين
ادويه في العالم وفي مصر هما جلاكسي سميث
كلاين
وفايزر
و وقفت وقلت لا انا عارف انا مش عايز ايه
انا مش هشتغل ده واقعد من غير شغل احسن ما
اشتغل حاجه انا ما بحبهاش وبعديها رحت
اشتغلت في شركه تامين مندوب تامين تخيلوا
معايا كم التريقه
والضغط والسلبيه اللي بتجيلك من كل اللي
حواليك من اهلك ومن اصحابك وحتى الناس
اللي بيشتغلوا معاك في نفس الشركه بيقول
لك يا ابني انت مجنون انت دكتور صيدلي ايه
اللي جايبك تشتغل هنا ايه اللي جابني
اشتغل هنا عشان انا مش عايز اشتغل صيدلي
دي مش حياتي ومش هينفع افضل قاعد كده لازم
اتحرك لغايه لما اكتشف
حاجه ان انت تقول لا مش سهله زي ما قلت
لكم محتاجه تمرين الموضوع كبير جدا
الموضوع في الاول بيجي معاه مسؤوليه لازم
يبقى عندك
مسؤوليه
المسؤوليه بتيجي من
ان لازم تتحمل القرار ده القرار ده ممكن
يبقى كويس وممكن يبقى وحش لازم تتحمل
الثنين وانا برض في الكليه نرجع للكليه
تاني وانا في سنه رابعه تعبت شويه قبل
الامتحانات باسبوعين والدكتور جه قال لي
انت مش ينفع تدخل الامتحانات انت لازم
تقعد في البيت انا وقفت قلت لا انا هذاكر
وهنزل الامتحانات اوكي وفعلا ذاكرت ونزلت
الامتحانات وكلكم هتفتكر ان في قصه نجاح
ورا الموضوع ده الحقيقه ان انا سقطت في كل
الموادع اللي انا دخلتها وعدت السنه وتعبت
اكتر بس كنت متحمل مسؤوليه القرار بتاعي
اوكي تاني حاجه تيجي مع ال مع ان انت تقف
وتقول لا هي الالتزام ان انت لازم تلتزم
بالقرار بتاعك لازم تفضل معاه للاخر مهما
كان الناس اللي بتحاول ترجعك عنه انت خدت
قرار كمل فيه للاخر حتى لو القرار ده
اتاخر الموضوع زي ما قلت لكم ساعات
بيبقى مؤذي ساعات انت بتخسر ساعات كتير
انت بتندم بس في الاخر الموضوع مجدي لو
انت هتعمل اللي انت بتحبه او هترفض تعمل
اللي انت ما بتحبوش في الاخر الموضوع
هيبقى مجدي انا بعد ما سبت شركه التامين
اللي انا كنت فيها اشتغلت في الشركه اللي
انا فيها حاليا بقالي فيها لات سنين وهقول
لكم الموضوع كان مجدي معايا ازاي ان انا
في اللات سنين دول بعد ما لقيت الحاجه
اللي انا بحب اعملها وبقيت الحاجه اللي
انا ببدع فيها الحمد لله اترقيت لات مرات
في الثلاث سنين وبقيت اول واحد مصري عنده
26 سنه يبقى هدف تكنولوجي
لمصر
[تصفيق]
الموضوع مجدي ممكن يتاخر وممكن تندم انا
كنت ممكن اندم على ان انا قلت لا لشركات
الادويه الكبيره جدا كنت ممكن اندم ان انا
قلت لا لكليه الصيدله بس اللي انا عايزك
تبقى متاكد منه واللي انا متاكد منه ان
انا كنت هندم اكتر بكتير جدا ان انا اعمل
الحاجه اللي انا ما بحبهاش واعيش العيشه
اللي انا مش عايز
اعيشها انا النهارده مش جاي اقوللكم قولوا
لا وخلاص مش جاي اقوللكم قولوا لا للعند
مش عايز مش جاي اقوللكم خالف تعرف انا كل
اللي عايز اقوله لكم ما تعملش حاجه انت مش
بتحبها ما تعملش حاجه انت مش موافق عليها
وما تخافش انك تقف وتقول لا
شكرا